we gotta get serious you guys we have
this story from NBC News law enforcement
agencies are prepping for a possible
Trump indictment as early as next week
oh I've actually seen rumors that
they're gonna they're gonna try and perp
walk Trump next week
I mean I'm really excited because it
means I'll have a video to make that
will get a million views so there's
always always good news for me when they
talk about arresting a guy unjustly you
know again oh geez look at this unjust
behavior from Joe Biden 300 000th time
what it what are the what are the
charges that they're expecting
discussing potentials hush money payment
to Stormy Daniels
that's all they could get against them
they're gonna perp walk a former
president over that
wow they're scared of trump man yeah
they are and maybe they so I don't know
if you guys watched the culture War
podcast with uh Sovereign bro but he was
talking about how people believe Trump
is the Antichrist
this is fascinating I think that there
it's based in it could be You could
argue this this is I didn't see the show
yet this is Chase I don't think you can
literally argue it I think people will
find things about anybody to stick to
the the you know prophecy or whatever
and so they just look at Trump we've got
a storied life and then try and apply
prophecy to wherever they can and so
basically like you could probably apply
Revelation to Phil in some way you know
if you find enough out about him you can
be like did you know that it was six
months six days and six hours after he
was born that there was an eclipse or
something people go whoa It's like you
could find that number anywhere and then
play a songs backwards yep oh God were
you saying I think Jenny and there's
going to be a song where it's just like
you're not really saying anything
backwards but people are going to be
adamant you're saying you know I am the
Antichrist
my mom
my mom was convinced that uh Judas
Priest was telling people to kill
themselves back in the 80s she was that
was one band that she was not cool with
me listening to I had like Iron Maiden I
was like super I was hiding Iron Maiden
records because if she saw the number of
the Beast she saw that record it was
over those were going out too but she
was she I I couldn't stop her from look
at it
this is some of the greatest stuff
Donnie darkened Donald Trump is the
chosen Antichrist they have been
foreshadowing this for centuries here
was the proof read before interacting
with my profile
yo this is so funny he says I've been
saying this saying for a while that
Satan's plan has always been about
destruction and rebirth order out of
chaos I believe that the true Beast
Kingdom will be the one that Humanity
will fight for rather than against like
I agree with that like the woke people
are fighting for the complete
destruction like they I I do not think
Trump is the Antichrist in fact I think
he's the resistance too if anything's if
I was going to make an argument Klaus
Schwab probably makes better sense but I
guess the issue is the Antichrist is
supposed to be a charismatic charismatic
leader with like military prowess or
something why is he always American the
Antichrist is always an American person
who did they think the Antichrist was
based on Nostradamus was it Saddam
[Music]
for whoever was you know the the most
recent bad guy I feel like there's been
multiple people making arguments that
person X or Y is the Antichrist oh yeah
yeah and maybe maybe when I think an
alleged predecessor to the third
Antichrist
when I think of Christ I think of energy
like they call Jesus of Nazareth after
he was gone or maybe during his life
they started calling him the Christ
because he possessed that energy that it
means anointed it means Christ to be
Christ is to be anointed by God anointed
one I think yeah so the Antichrist is
the anti-anointed and that doesn't have
to be one individual it could be Joel
Osteen it could be people that are
betraying the Faith by making money off
of it and it's just erupting in a bunch
of people at once just like the return
of dude Christ is going to erupt in a
bunch of people that want to
I just got to say this
Donald Trump means Herald of the world
ruler
Herald of the world ruler so that's my
generous interpretation Donald is
Scottish Gaelic for World ruler and
Trump references the the trumpet sound
of heralding in something that the
trumpet blast so my argument was when we
were reading about Ingersoll Lockwood
books from the 1800s that predicted like
Baron Trump or whatever I'm like Barons
the real guy because his name is Baron
like if there was going to be a super
villain it wouldn't be the guy who
Heralds the world ruler it would be the
baron the sound and have you seen him
he's like eight feet tall yeah and I I
you know I you don't want to see him
when he's angry because he gets bigger
hey man he's been quiet and he does look
like that's the thing you don't want to
abuse people like Andrew Tate sitting in
prison he's gonna come out radical more
radical than before that's the problem
with people insulting Donald Trump all
day all day that's hurting Baron that's
making him crazy in a way and if he does
end up getting power with that Trump
name and he's Twisted because of the way
he was abused as a kid because of his
association with his dad that's not good
let me let me ask you guys though
there's there's like an element of
excitement to Donald Trump being the
Antichrist and you all you all know it
everyone agrees right like Trump Rises
up and he's floating through the air and
he's like levitating and he's like his
eyes start glung and then he fires a
lightning blast and like destroys a
building and you're like what does this
have to do with the prophecy or whatever
but you know like there's a there's an
element of excitement to Great
historical change and historical moments
where I think a lot of people I'm being
I'm only half kidding actually a lot of
people are looking for purpose
desperately and if Donald Trump did turn
out to be some prophesized world leader
be it the Antichrist or the one who
stops him or whatever you want to call
it like people are desperate for some
kind of great Great War of our of Our
Generation I feel like that's one of the
things that motivates a lot of people
that are
um and anarchists on the left I don't
feel like it's so much uh anarchists on
the right but the anarchists on the left
are very much uh it seems to me that
they have a the desire to kind of tear
the system down like tear everything
down because they believe the system is
unjust and they believe that any other
system that comes in its place is going
to be better which is probably the
opposite of true like we probably have
about the best system that we can kind
of dude get away with I gotta play this
video and
I hadn't brought you in by now oh
heavens you would have died
she stroked his pretty skin again
and kissed him
and held him tight
but instead of saying thank you
that snake gave her a vicious bite
[Applause]
take me an otender woman
Take Me In For Heaven's Sake Take Me In
o tender woman side The Vicious sake
whoa I have saved you
cried the woman
and you've bitten me Heaven's why
you know your bite is his business and
now I'm going to die
oh shut up
silly woman
a reptile with a grin you knew damn well
I was a snake before you took me in
so the argument is he's saying Trump is
confessing
to like all the people around him that
oh what some just fall sorry my purse oh
they're arguing that Trump is outright
telling you he's the snake or whatever
I've got to say I do not think he is the
Antichrist I'm reading about a little
bit the Antichrist apparently is an
imposter is like purporting to be the
second coming or Christ that's why I
think of these pastors that have these
mega churches like Joel Osteen like he's
telling people that he's a vessel of God
yeah but the Antichrist is supposed to
have military prowess Charisma a special
look about him you know what I mean
besides like the the Antichrist as
opposed to usher in the mark of the
beast which is something that affects
all people that bars you from buying or
trading unless you bear the mark and
it's not like Donald Trump executed any
kind of program like that yeah what if
he didn't do warp speed yeah we did do
warp speed yeah he did do oh yeah that's
right he did do it that's he did do that
that's one joke yeah I tried to make it
funny
you were either saying that before the
show Jenny well he did all of that he
did Operation War speed he did 15 days
to slow the spread or whatever he was
bringing in fouchy like he is that
person so maybe I think like in 2024
like that's gonna be maybe something
that DeSantis or whoever it is can go
after him for because people are upset
about that like certainly in his base
not only are people upset about that but
he has done nothing to walk it back
because he's Donald Trump and and
everything that he does he it's it's all
he doesn't walk he never wants anything
back this is my favorite he's just gonna
be like oh it's fine like Donald Trump's
famous 666 hand sign oh my God
syndrome is real it's absolutely real he
makes people crazy man it's both
manufactured and organic like obviously
the military the liberal I don't want to
blame the military industrial complex
anymore I'm done doing that Lockheed
Martin's doing its job it's prevented
World War III they're building the
weapons we have used to protect the
world all right I'm gonna say it better
or worse it's going to be 20 years from
now and Ian is going to be singing a
throne of skulls it's the economic we're
going to be like it was Ian though not
the Antichrist my promise what it's the
economic system that's the real threat
uh these these weapons manufacturers are
doing weapons manufacturers do they
always have it's the economic system a
liberal economic order that's the
problem and that's the thing that's
seated doubt about this guy they didn't
like this guy because he was throwing a
wrench into the transition into the New
World Order what if like we're all
laughing but Ian actually does become
the vice president under Trump
I will pay extra in taxes so that way
the Secret Service is extra well funded
to protect the life of Donald Trump
should Ian be the vice president dude
what if me and Donald Trump were the
Christ and the Antichrist because
they're supposed to oppose each other
and I would just be like no no are you
saying you're the bad guy I would I
would just be his opposite I'm not going
to let him steamroll people and be cruel
I will not let that happen but if I was
just fixing things what if Ian I mean
isn't that how it was like now after the
fact how Trump views Mike Pence
like isn't it that kind of thing no
you're saying that Pence is the
Antichrist no I mean in his view
absolutely they're kind of at odds right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time